vérifiez vérifier encore ne rien laisser
au hasard ces deux jeunes pilotes de
l'aéro club paul tissandier de
saint-cyr-l'ecole achève les derniers
préparatifs avant de décoller malgré
leur menu expérience le protocole semble
pour eux un exercice routinier alors là
c'est la jauge d'huile de l'avion
exactement comme sur une voiture donc on
vérifie que le niveau d'huile est
suffisant avant chaque vol donc là on
voit qu'il est entre 5 et 6 c dans les
cédants les tolérances dont c'est fait
cette passion pour les airs ils y ont
tous les deux découvertes alors qu'ils
étaient enfants
mais moi j'ai découvert le
l'aéronautique tout petit en fait mon
père était instructeur et de l'est
toujours d'ailleurs et il m'a emmené
donc je devais avoir trois ans et je me
souviens d'un tour de piste que j'ai
effectué donc c'est un tour autour de
l'aéroport et ça m'a vraiment
impressionné et vers l'âge de 15 ans
j'ai j'ai poussé la porte de l'aéro club
avec la volonté d'apprendre à piloter
donjon en effet inscrit ici à l'aéro
club paul tissandier il s'entraîne
depuis cinq ans et ont tous deux réussi
leur brevet de pilotage un parcours sans
faute qui les a conduits au tour de
france des jeunes pilotes l'été dernier
deux semaines de vol de clermont ferrand
aux côtes normandes ils ont été
sélectionnés en même temps que 43 autres
jeunes techniquement au niveau du
pilotage et humainement ça a été super
enrichissant une des meilleures choses
que j'ai fait dans ma vie je pense pour
l'instant et ils ont garderai toute ma
vie un super secours aujourd'hui à 20
ans passés ils terminent leurs études
d'ingénieur à l'estaca et affinent leur
projet professionnel
un avenir que chacun voit forcément dans
les airs et j'aimerais passer en
parallèle ma licence de pilote
professionnel qui permet de devenir
instructeur et éventuellement aussi
partir sur un métier qui me permettrait
de combiner de l'ingénierie et le
pilotage par exemple les essais les
essais en vol ce qui m'intéresserait
beaucoup
j'hésite à postuler pour pour faire
l'armée de l'air ou peut-être en
hélicoptère dans l'armée de terre et
voilà mais je me vois vraiment en a vu
un avenir dans l'aviation
en tant pilote des carrières exigeante
mais ce n'est pas ce qui stoppera les
deux intrépides yvelinois la difficulté
à tyr l'homme de caractère a un jour dit
un grand homme